well I just wanted to introduce everyone
to Angela Arendt just as a little bit of
background on how all of this
happen you all know I was just in
England two weeks ago and as part of
that you you came to the talk
yeah at the London School of Economics
and then the next day we met at Heathrow
Airport yeah
I and my $6 old navy shirt feeling very
insecure the entire time and both Esther
and I were there and you inspired us and
and so when you said you were going to
be in this area we're like well we would
love you to do the same thing with with
the team just talk about what you're
doing etcetera etcetera
if you could talk a little bit about
just how you I mean fashion in the world
of fashion is this world that means it's
not obvious to most people how does
someone get into it and especially get
to the level that you've gotten how did
you start and and what kind of at least
at the early stages allowed you to get
here I mean honestly it's not a
dissimilar story to yours right so my
thing is is you you know I think the
greatest thing that anybody can do when
they're young is is discover their
passion and what they love and I know it
sounds really really terrible but I love
stuff and I love to shop and I love
fashion magazines and I love to sew and
create and and so I was the only
industry I had the had to get into but I
went to university and in signed up for
all these design classes and realized I
really wasn't that creative but I had a
really strong opinion on what everybody
else was doing and so I had a professor
say that we call you a merchant and like
okay and so then I signed up for a lot
of merchandising and marketing courses
so so my my university degree is in
merchandising and marketing so so in in
the world of what we do I always say I'm
the monkey in the middle
we have Christopher Bailey who's the
chief creative officer and he is so
creative and so brilliant and his whole
creative team does all those videos but
then on and so that's my on my right and
on my left I have we have the chief
financial officer we have our chief
operating officer we have a number of
our teams that have just arrived as well
and so you have this balance so I would
say I'm a 50/50 I am half left brain and
Allah I am half right brained creative
and that was actually one of the reasons
that I wanted to chat with Sal because I
said someday as you guys start to take
over the world you're going to have to
also
to introduce some right-brain curriculum
and you know when the Burberry
foundation would be honored to help you
start creating some of those things when
you're ready down the road oh yeah no
and we're already starting a little bit
we could talk more about that but no
absolutely and I think I mean you say
you're not creative I mean that I think
you're really underselling you yeah yeah
dumb design creative yeah but you
haven't had a very strong aesthetic you
could you could you had a sense for what
were what what yeah yeah yeah again I'm
absolutely yeah absolutely a merchant
and I will tell you what the reason
Christopher and I created the foundation
is is because we are both creative
thinkers right and and we feel very
strongly that the curriculum
specifically in America has become so
left-brain so much of the arts and
things have been cut out but it is I
think for where the world's going we
need creative thinkers we need and so
many times they're getting lost out of
the system yeah so we created the
Burberry foundation we give one percent
of our profits into the Burberry
foundation and what we do is we try and
pick up the youth that is starting to
fall out of the system because they
think they're dumb because they don't so
hopefully we can help turn them on to
you guys to help them but you know if
they're still just not left brain but
they're incredibly creative thinking so
we bring as many of them in as we can we
make weave show them a whole nother
world but companies like this need and
and that's kind of been our colleague ya
know it's it's incredible and I mean you
yourself you know you said okay I'll be
a merchant a professor tells you this
and and and you just go to New York and
then what you're not even 30 and you're
the president of Donna Karan is that
right yeah yeah how does how does how
does that happen and is that normal are
there a lot of 20-somethings running a
major fashion houses in the world
probably not and probably not and and I
will tell you I'm really guilty cuz I'm
not great talking about myself I'm just
not because you know I'm only as good
always as the great teams that are
around me and no different than you guys
and and so yes I I have I think what
happens always is when you discover who
you are and you discover your passion
and then it's not work at your life and
so you just you just
to that zone in you and so I was so
fortunate that you know met the right
people things fell into place absolutely
worked my butt off because you know I
was single alone in New York and why not
it's all I did was so it you know but I
found my zone I found you know I was
there a moment where I mean did I just
find you know if a member of my family
says hey I'm gonna go to New York and
I'm gonna go work in fast like okay you
know I'll see if I can help support you
at some point or I just left the left
breast it was left brain side of me but
but I mean how did you I mean break it
in and then obviously left such a big
mark with people that you by the time
you weren't even 30 or you're president
of a major major fashion organization
but you know Sonny I don't think of it
any different than a great athlete or a
musician or a you know I think that what
happens is this is all that I've ever
done and so i I've always just stayed in
my lane and and you know and then you
become you know whether you're a
footballer or whether you're you know I
didn't jump around this is all that I've
done and and and I have always been so
passionate about it and I think when you
direct your energy and you become so
passionate and you unite people right
and you lead people all around believing
in something and then things just fall
into place anything and I know that when
I say things the revenue the profit
right so I never went in saying I'm
gonna do this right you know I went in
saying you know what if we did this you
know and I've always I've always you
know I've always been a dreamer you know
my father used to always say take off
your Rhodes coloured glasses and I would
always say no and now I don't have to I
can keep dreaming yes but the important
thing I've learned is though I have to
get enough people right I have to
surround myself with enough people that
can help execute that dream now and and
and that's that's all that I've ever
done and I don't want to oversimplify it
but you know I found my zone I
absolutely love what I do it is not work
at all I have never once woken up the
mornings that oh god I gotta go to work
it's not work this is my life and you
know and everywhere that I've been I
because it's not work and you know the
mantra at Burberry or anywhere that I've
been
because the the stronger companies get
then the more they can do
and the bigger influence they have you
know and so at Burberry we've always
said that you know that we have the
power to touch and transform lives
through the power of our performance and
the bigger the stronger we get the more
we can do and that's just always been
you know I'm from the heart of Midwest
you know real strong family faith
upbringing and and and you know and I I
have been raised to give that's you know
that's how I was raised and so why
wouldn't you apply that back in business
and and so just yeah I mean I think you
are under selling yourself a little bit
but but but I'll let you I'll give you a
pass on that but but I do want because I
think the interesting thing about these
and why we video them is I think just a
Khan Academy user base here there's a
lot of young people out there who would
see how do i how do i do that and if you
had advice for someone who's 16 years
old or 20 years old and and they've they
find this world intriguing oh absolutely
what should they develop in themselves
and and and how should they think about
the world and then what should they do
well and I always say to the fashion
industry is deceiving because everybody
just thinks it's only this creative part
we're in a company like Burberry there
are 18 different departments that can
price the company so we need we hire a
lot of people from Silicon Valley we
need great we have a hundred and thirty
people just in the IT department in the
company right people don't realize that
so we need extreme right and we need
extreme left I think sometimes the
fashion industry gets a short it's the
short stick sometimes when they think oh
it's just what is fashion it's just you
know so so in order to create and here's
my thing I always say that what we're
doing is we're creating a great brand
and a great company and we happen to be
in the business of fashion right we
didn't set out to create a really great
fashion we set out to create a great
brand and and I and I say that because
there's a part of me that says that is
your mission as well and so what I've
been following on that but I do want to
think about well what I mean what in
your mind is what does a brand mean I've
heard multiple definitions of a brand
and how would you view Burberry's brand
and and how would you view our brand
they're very similar that's boring
aligning overcoats um to meet a great
brand and here's my thing think of
yourself and when you interact with
products right what coffee do you drink
every morning or you know you might walk
into Starbucks or you might walk into
but what do you you know you might have
Apple products you might write so what
is how do you feel about and so you you
want to be a part of that brand right
because you're proud to be a part of
that brand because that brand makes you
feel a certain way and you trust that
brand and it's authentic and it doesn't
ever let you down it exceeds your
expectations so you want to engage with
it right and so so those are all of the
attributes of a great brand honesty
integrity authenticity quality you know
but but always doing what you you know
to have a great great engagement or or
the word great great brand presence you
there has to be a very trusting
relationship with your constituency and
in that way we are absolutely because
your your you know your users they have
to trust what you're telling them I mean
and if you're wrong
yes happens ever know that but it's a so
to me that it's a part of what a great
brand is and in a Burberry's case and
that's how we measure it and how do you
think about these things you know mm you
joined Burberry in 2006 I guess in the
previous five or ten years Burberry had
kind of been rejuvenated so if you could
talk a little bit about that
rejuvenation before you got there and
then how you know when you got took over
the job and what do you tell yourself
how are you going to steer the ship you
know what I think happens that again
were 158 years old and you guys are
right but but what's you're building
right now no but so so we had gone
through a lot and so we got the whole
management team together you're starting
out that way but we got the team
together and said what is our core what
is our core product proposition and and
what's our core purpose
and so so you know we we realized that
you know 158 150 years then but 158
years ago now we were born from a coat
we had our own weaving facility in the
north of England we had our own factory
that produced all of those coats but but
it's interesting we were driving
innovation everywhere else but in our
core product and I want everyone talked
about global warming and they gave me
all the reasons why we couldn't do that
and it was kind of no no every great
brand every great brand what would
Starbucks be without coffee I mean every
great brand has to have a core and I
think people get bored with that but but
as you grow bigger and bigger what is
your core product proposition and don't
ever lose it and keep innovating that
core because people get bored really
easy but then also what is your core
purpose and and you know because I don't
believe people just want to work
I think people all want deeper meaning
in their lives you know and it was hard
for us people don't you know people
don't just want to make stuff people
want to make stuff that has meaning and
has a purpose and and so art we created
our core values which are to protect
explore and inspire and we didn't come
up with those we took those out of a
book that Thomas Burberry wrote 158
years ago when he was 21 years old he
founded the company and you know we
always say his spirit lives on and it
should because it was his company it was
his vision and he created that
waterproof gabardine fabric to protect
the military in the trenches that's why
he created the trench coat etc so we
said that is our core that's what he
founded the company on how do we make
the trench coat the most cool relevant
hip thing in the world what we were born
from nobody else can say that but us and
so to revitalize and transform the
company we simply went back to the
basics we went back and revitalized our
core and we took that category which was
about 22% of the business seven and a
half eight years ago today it's half of
the business and when you watch a runway
show nearly every item that goes down
has some type of a trench coat or some
type of so the innovation that we've
driven in that core and that has
single-handedly Harvard
this review did a great article on on
just that topic revitalizing the core
and I mean how you decide on it is that
just a a gut instinct I mean or do is
there some data that you look at oh we
you know look at all the brands that
have a core versus don't have a core I
mean how did or is it just a and on that
and then as you move and and continue to
innovate and get new products I'm sure
every day someone comes through hey we
should have a line of whatever it might
be how do you how do you decide how much
of it is is analytically driven and how
much of it is gut or whatever else
driven the great it's a great question
it's a great question so I'm going to
answer it three ways so one is we always
say that we are a creative thinking
company and and everything we do is
driven by intuition and then we confuse
ourself with facts but we always always
lead with intuition and because we
always say that we do value feeling over
knowing because if we only focused on
knowing we've never moved forward
because you can't prove something that
hasn't been done before so so we are we
are and that is a part of being a
creative thinking culture and I forgot
my other two leaders I told you there
were three and I came out so you confuse
yourself with facts I mean what does
that mean does that mean that you you
know you feel or collectively not just
you the whole organization feels like
something's the right direction but what
if someone says hey but look you know
everyone who's gone into this space
before has failed the arts there's eight
hundred players already in that market
that you know what they get zero margin
on what they're doing it's being you
know it's a commodity do you ignore that
do you sometimes ignore that do you say
no I we still feel good about it and you
move ahead so so so so again we so seven
years ago came up with all the hard we
call them hard strategies and those are
all the ones that are very fact-based
right so when we talked about retail led
growth brought in a consultant company
told us I said tell me every key market
in the world that has where our peers
have at least two stores and we have
none right so and then tell me their
productivity per square foot so we had a
strategy put all the hard metrics behind
it and but but the gut Kate you know our
instincts were we were 75 percent
wholesale when I started to
day we are 75% retail our own stores
direct-to-consumer so so we are instinct
said we had to go direct to consumer we
had to control the brand the environment
everything and and so then again brought
in the firm but we did that on every
strategy and and and they would reaffirm
etc so then I put them in front of the
board very first been the company six
months strategies are done everything is
outlined we know exactly where we're
going and at the very end they told the
board and we said at that point in time
we would double the revenue and the
profits in five years and they the guy
that I won't mention the company on
video but the guy stands up the end of
the meeting and he tells and the board
says well how do you feel about this
going through it and he says there's
about a 5% probability that they will do
this and who is who's this guy well he
works for a huge consulting firm and I'm
not going to okay alright but we had
them come in and for six months we had
them you know work with us on validating
these strategies right and so the
strategy was based there was a number
strategy where you're looking at the
retail density and different geographies
and how productive those stores are and
so that is what you use to decide where
you're going to go or yeah again there's
always there's always both there's
always the well known that was the other
part of the thing I just forgot so one
was intuition but the other is balance
right right so we talked a lot about the
right and the left right a lot so when
when when we had hard five hard
strategies and we had five soft
strategies so the foundation was the
soft strategy the culture was the saw
all of the company comp and been free
lunch the benefits for all of this stuff
were all the soft strategies and we said
that these will enable those but just
focusing on these you know we may not
get the job done so they the consulting
firm didn't work with us on the soft
things they only worked with us on the
hard so when they told the board there's
only a 5% probability you know the board
kind of like we're nuts but we actually
achieved the plan a year early and they
thought it was a 5% probability cuz
they've advised you on a lot of the fact
part they thought we were being regard
to aggressive but are they aggressive
when you said you're going to double
your revenues and profit and find it in
five years that was the part that they
were giving you five percent problem
absolutely they said no you I'm sure
you'll grow etc etc yeah but but to
really
really and and the soft things are just
stuff that felt right was this the soft
things were but that we knew we knew I
knew that that we would be as good as
our people and that we had to we had to
build a team we had to unite and connect
this culture and they had to believe in
the dream right and and this is
leadership this is you know and they had
to lead everybody so we were 3,200
people then and they some of the we had
people have been with a 30 years 40
years right but how do you get everybody
United around a new vision a new dream
and in it and the thing is is they have
to believe every single person has to
believe you can do this you know that's
the positive energy that that comes
around something when you are breaking
new ground or or trying to do something
transformative like you are and if
they're if they don't believe you know
and I I told them up front after that
six months I said if you do not believe
that we're going to do this then maybe
you should go now
right because it we you know we knew we
wanted to do something really big and
transformative so so you know we used
our instincts we confused ourselves with
facts and then we build a very balanced
strategy hard and soft very balanced
teams so you know we need creatives but
we need operational excellence and the
strategies were built that way and so
you know I I always say in every single
store we have we need left brain and we
need right in every country in every
region because I don't think you'll
build a great brand that resonates and
touches people without both you know you
need the engagement but you need the
reach and they're very different and and
the projection of doubling there's no
precedent for this I mean that's why it
was that's probably wiser well the
precedent was they had done it before I
see and the probability of a company
doing it twice was what really took the
odds down right and I mean through that
process were there moments where I mean
you know you yourself for like gee I
don't know if this is gonna happen you
know I've gotten you were just never
never that's why I am to never doubt
never
I'm always doubted you are not no you're
not no I think he's a bigger dream than
I am we can compete yeah but you have to
because you are on you are you are
disrupting a sector that is so overdue
to be disruptive it is so overdue and
the next generation is in your hands and
they need you to do this the country
needs you to do what you're doing
you got to do it and you got to keep
going and you got to get your reach out
there you are engaging I mean the fact
that 30,000 teachers are using your
content in schools you know it's
unbelievable get it to a hundred get it
to 200 I mean just don't stop can you
Skype into our company updates it'll be
very I wish hi I wanna let's let's do
this let's it's less yeah but that's how
I feel yeah I mean that is how I feel
you and if you and it's not gonna be
easy
yeah but don't stop yeah I mean what I
well that that by itself is really
powerful advice at feed I mean what
would you tell us I mean as we go
everywhere that you know you're a
hundred fifty eight years old 150 eight
weeks old I mean how do we
hahaha any advice for her I mean beyond
that just kind of ultra focus believe
power through mm-hmm definitely focus
yeah you know and we still do the same
thing today we always say that every
year we only do three new things that's
it because you know they take in and we
call the big brand moments I mean
whether it was launching Burberry calm I
mean it took us a year to unite
thousands of people around the world you
know and we said that we had to do this
and we had one chance to change a
hundred and fifty years of perception so
we knew that you know we knew that that
that and and and this year they'll be
pretty close to a hundred million people
to go onto Burberry calm I know you guys
are up to a lot but for a luxury brand
that's a lot that's pretty good it's a
lot yeah and and not a buying but
engaging you know and spreading what the
brands about etc so so but three things
a year and and we still hold on to that
no matter how that's not individual
products that is
new initiatives like Burberry comm
exactly three big brand things that we
unite 10,000 people around the world to
do right and and what's kind of next in
the queue what are the three things
y'all are doing now it's probably no
surprise that we are aggressively
working on our continuing to work on our
digital platform and specifically when
it comes to mobile I mean the whole
world was becoming mobile and you know
it's just it's crazy all the metrics of
the consumers that are engaging and and
you know and that's probably a challenge
you guys to because that is where you'll
get your kid that is where you know on a
mobile device not just a phone but any
mobile device I mean the whole world
it's just so heavy investment you know a
lot of focus going there so digital
mobile etc and and we also then we
always have operational or internal
initiatives as well so we do as we get
big you know areas get sloppy so we
still have to drive a lot of
efficiencies out of the business so we
call it commercial procurement we're
building you know we build tons of
stores a year so we've hired some
additional expertise to make sure we're
doing that in the most efficient way and
so I mean right now if you ask any of
our executives around the world they
know those are the three things that
we're focused on this year and and and
if we do those right we will put up the
results that we've that we budgeted etc
well and you are going fast I mean for a
large company I'll group twenty four
twenty five percent last year it's
frankly we just we just put up this
year's results we just did our trading
update a couple weeks ago and our retail
business was up 13 percent on it on a
really really big base and that's not
what global retail is doing today no no
our largest competitor put up a three
percent retail business and they're the
biggest in the sector so right right
yeah so no we're absolutely continues
outperform but I will tell you it's
because it's the people because there
are 10,000 people around the world that
are so passionate about this company and
and so passionate about our performance
and creating again a great brand a
really great company but but you know
they also know that every time we open a
flagship store because again you know
it's kind of shallow luxury retail right
and so and that always bothered
Christopher and I because it's not where
we came from right we love what we're
doing
and that's why we've been focused on a
great company but every time we open a
flagship store we partner with a local
institution so in Chicago we partnered
with hive and we gifted them a million
dollars and we created a program to help
the youth in the Chicago area with our
programs Burberry beyond etc so we've
done it in New York we've done it in
Beijing we're getting ready to do it in
Shanghai so anytime we open up this huge
luxury store which could come across a
little you know elitist if you will we
always make sure that the company also
you know we are we like in New York we
said we're lighting up Manhattan with
the store well we're also going to light
up people's life
when we gave the million dollars to the
Robin Hood Foundation and put our
program in place for the Chartered
schools etc so you know with that and
that's a big part of the balance and
that's a part of being a great company
when you look in the organization you
must be looking at people oh look at
look at him look at her mm that's she's
got some potential he's got some
potential hey that that could be my that
could be the the next CEO what are you
looking at what are the traits that
you're seeing in those people that are
really striking you as someone who might
be able to one day step into your shoes
mm-hmm
it's a great question and we look at it
honestly at all levels of the company
and and I and I would even say probably
yes my shoes right because you know that
would mostly be a lot of my direct
reports etc so I I would tell you at
every level of the company and we hire
for it as well so sounds terrible but we
culturally compatible yeah right we
always say we don't want tissue
rejection because it you know it's tough
to bring people into your culture tissue
rejection like Oh on these great skin
grafting yeah yes and we just don't want
wrong what helps okay so so so people go
through such rigor before we bring them
into the company and we always say are
they culturally compatible right do we
trust them um do we like them obviously
but do we trust them do we believe them
do they believe in our mission and what
we're doing because I you know we can't
afford to make a mistake so so so I
would tell you with anybody going to the
next level there is transparency trust
our core values though all those soft
things we talked about
they reach a certain level of it's a
given they're smart it's a given they
have high IQ but we need high EQ you
know and and I we say that everybody in
the company needs a little right and
left brain bite to extremes because then
they don't feel and you know and we
always say that you know we can teach
people anything but we can't teach them
to care we can't teach them to feel and
when you're in a human business and
you're communicating like we're
communicating you know they have to be
authentic they have to you know we have
a we have a Leadership Council which is
the next generation talent and and we
spend hours just helping them understand
who they are who are they right because
then only if they really know who they
are can they build very balanced teams
around them and and it's a real self
reflective phase that they go through
but they will become better leaders
having peace and confidence with who
they are and you know to thy self be
true and and and so that is a part of
our talent plan and and and you know and
I we say no different than me you know I
tell investors you would be so surprised
at every decision I don't make every day
but you can't right right I have to
trust the people we brought in and I
have to give them very simple clear
messages you know well three things
we're gonna do this year right and all
the metrics behind it and you know and
uniting everyone but it is trust
intuition great communication
authenticity people have to feel them or
they will never rise as a leader in the
company right and I mean is it something
that you think you can I mean you talk
about personality fit and cultural fit
you trust them but is there some way
that you can you can screen for that for
that that balance of you know the whole
brain I read the whole book now but a
very good book is is a way that we meet
I did I read on the plane there's a long
flight is I gave him a copy of Daniel
Pink's book it's called the whole mind
why right-brainers will rule the world
and and and one and and one thing that I
pointed out to you because one thing
that I did react to that book it's funny
because in that
they says oh we don't need programmers
anymore we need inventors I said well
what's a programmer it's an adventure it
is a fundamentally a right brained
activity and so I actually most strong
so when people say oh you know Khan
Academy stem I was like stem is it
should be a right brained activity it's
I mean the in my mind the the learning
the factor polynomial or to do a or to
do the basics of algorithmic that's
that's like a painter learning how to
paint but the real expression is when
you actually create something so I
actually think we're more similar than I
think so to then work but I think that's
what you've unlocked I think that's your
unique brand positioning the creative
your tape taking what most people would
would take as a traditional left-brain
and you're adding we're adding fun to it
you're adding energy to it and you're
making it you know you're you're you're
combining you're making it you're making
it more of a right-left brain exercise
not just a an analytical exercise yeah
yeah no no and and how we're doing on
time okay three more minutes so I will
ask you again because it was so
inspiring and the dopamine just start we
talking about dopamine earlier I got us
all very excited I won't ask yeah we
were ten we were talking about well and
other things but the I mean just at
parting words advice for the team here
and and people look good Reiter Khan
Academy community thoughts on on just
what we should be doing and how we can
approach life yeah you know you are it's
funny because I had the honor right
before the Olympics mr. Bill Gates was
in London and had a wonderful luncheon
and and we'd met a couple of different
times and I had the honour sitting next
to him at the luncheon table and he was
talking about all of his different
philanthropic efforts etc and and to the
who's who of the UK if you will and and
he hadn't mentioned the Khan Academy and
and I was so excited why you know so at
the very end he simply said is there
anything else and I said well what are
your plans for the Khan Academy and he
kind of looked at me like how do I know
about about this and nobody in the room
knew about it and these are huge big
executives running Glaxo and every big
company in the UK and and so it he then
went on to share with them what you were
doing and why that he
you know felt strongly and when and you
know his foundation was investing etc
and and then the luncheon broke and then
he looked at me and he goes well what
would you do you know would and I and I
said you created the greatest brand in
the world Microsoft I mean you you know
and you just you were so laser and you
had such a vision and I said it is
absolutely no different with the Khan
Academy I believe you have the ability
to create one of the greatest brands and
one of the greatest companies in the
world his I said I told him I said when
you did it there was a need and you
filled that need there is a tremendous
need and you are filling that need and
it's in a different way but you're using
and you're leveraging the technology
that exists today as he did and and and
he then sent a follow-up note afterwards
saying you know could we continue the
conversation I found it you know I found
it fascinating etc and I shared this
with you because to have at this young
age that you are to have someone of his
vision and his caliber believed in you
you know you know you know you're on the
right track and and and I just think
that you know I am absolutely nothing in
comparison to the people that are
watching you the people that are
following you the lives that you're
you're impacting you're impacting
teachers lives you're impacting the next
generation you are actually impacting
people who didn't finish their education
who are going on and learning now and so
you know you will create a phenomenal
brand you will create an amazing company
and you are in the midst of disrupting a
sector that is so desperately in need of
being fixed and you're doing it in such
a modern way leveraging everything that
exists today and my counsel to you is
just don't stop and don't slow down and
and you know stay focused keep the right
pace but but do truly understand that
what you're doing has far greater
meaning than anything you've ever done
in your lives before and and not just as
America need you to do this the world
needs you to do this education is the
biggest issue that the
you know inhibiting future economies all
over the world so I just I just I am so
honored to be here and to chat with you
and and just I am so thankful for what
you're doing I really am well I feel
like going back to work now
No well thank you so much I mean this
was I mean for me personally when we met
in Heathrow with my $6 shirt on
that by itself was a really powerful I
mean Esther was there too and we were
like she's amazing and Esther is the
number one search result on Olympic
attitude on Google so she has authority
here but we were transfixed and blown
away by meeting you then and this I
think I think I could speak for everyone
where this was incredibly inspiring and
motivating for all of us so so thank you
so much now you're more than welcome
keep up the great work